Deion Sanders joins us right now good
morning what's up Prime
how you doing my brother I'm proud of
you you're looking good as usual well
thank you I appreciate it man proud of
you and you're looking good as usual as
well um now we're familiar with your
success as a player you talk about it
often we have watched you dominate on
the football field but what has made you
successful as a coach
um circling myself with a bunch of other
coaches that are really good that
understands relationships understands
these young men and attracting kids that
are smart tough ass discipline with
character and not allowing me kids to
coach us but we're implementing Those
Old School principles that you and I
grew up on and you and I adored playing
for someone that uh that accelerated
those principles and we just wants these
kids not to just rely on being a
professional football player we want
them to be professionals period
now as I mentioned you completely
transform what was going on at Jackson
State and the world was watching what is
it about that program that you will miss
now that you have moved on
um the people
we always say we want to change the
culture but until you change the people
you cannot fathom to change the culture
but I'm going to miss
so many of the people that are in that
um university that are amongst the city
that were just a blessing to me my kids
as well as the program I'm going to
truly miss the people if it wasn't for
Jackson State I wouldn't be here
you know um Deion Sanders I've been
watching this series number one it is so
good I was sitting there taking notes
because you are a quote a minute if you
have a plan B you won't make it when
your team lost a game and they they said
we left some meat on the bones collard
greens on the plate that's not good
enough
but it's the way that you talk to the
it's the way you talk to the kids but
also the way you live your life I was so
touched in the series where you talked
about you had your toes amputated two of
them because of blood clots and you said
the doctor came to you with an
expression you never want to see but you
said you don't anytime you go through
something bad it's worth it and you said
God always has you and it doesn't matter
just as long as I'm alive could you just
talk about how you got through that
because I was so moved by how you
handled that situation
now your teammates say that you're now
showing off your toes
but that was one of the uh the most
trying times of my life I mean you talk
about an athlete who prouded himself on
his body and his physical attributes now
I'm short I'm short two toes now they're
talking about an amputation of my whole
leg now they're talking about my life
and having you back up against the wall
and you're saying God I know darn well
you didn't bring me this far for this
and I trust God so much I never doubted
I never wavered I never even considered
the fact that I wasn't going to be here
to raise my kids and raise these
children in that coach not one bit uh my
faith was sustained how can you even
measure your faith if you're not
challenged so just going through that
whole time
um and seeing my kids migrate to the
hospital or something even want to see
their father like that but understood
that even through the trials and
tribulation I had to remain true to who
I was and what I believed anybody could
clap with everybody a wall with a nice
strut when everybody's clapping for you
but when you're on your back and you're
sitting there looking up you got to
remain consistent with who you are and
what you believe and that was the trying
time but what we made it through
coach let me ask you a question about uh
Demar Hamlin who's making a remarkable
incredible recovery
um in your position as a coach of young
men who hopefully will one day play in
the NFL what's your message to them
after they see that video and they see
what happened to Demar and maybe they're
feeling a little concerned about
themselves when they step out onto the
field what is the message to them
well first of all I had something I'm
praying for this young man and friends
family loved ones and uh anyone that's
close to him
I'm not going to say that's part of it
because it's not that could have
happened on anywhere on any player Nate
could uh tell you that wasn't even that
severe of a impactful hit or Collision
to prompt that that was just the timing
um what I'm going to do I'm going to
look forward to something that happened
through that through that he's going to
be all right and I trust God that he is
but do you see how he came together as a
country as a people
he wasn't black he wasn't white he
wasn't Hispanic he was an Asian he
wasn't anything but someone who we cared
about and we all came together as what
for that moment in that time and we're
still together I just want to understand
that cohesiveness that brought us
together and let's maintain that it
shouldn't take tragedy for us to come
together as a people and that's what I'm
on right now I want all of us to love
each other and sing about y'all just
like you do every morning you have a
collection of people in ethnicity and
social climates that you guys give us so
much love and and just realness and
Truth every morning that's why I enjoy
watching you you're perfect perfect
symbol of love you ever heard of
butterscotch though you talked about all
different people Nate yeah yeah that's
right we got chocolate camera
[Applause]
Dion so I want to get back to Jackson
State now you brought attention to not
only Jackson State hbcus you talked
about the funds
um you talked about the attention you
talked about filling the stadiums
putting butts in seats selling merch you
shed so much light on what needs to be
done at schools like that yet and still
when you left you were heavily
criticized how did you feel about it
it was ignorant come on man it was
ignorant but you got to understand the
people that are criticizing you um I
never listened to my my critics because
my critics have critics that's that's
one thing let's just get that straight
secondly you got to understand there's a
group of persons that are not
Progressive that don't want it that
ain't trying to go get it they don't
want to work they don't want us to do it
and dominate it that they're just
sitting there idle and pointing fingers
my my crowd is those people that are up
in the morning watching you guys getting
ready to go to work that's going to get
it has three or four kids that's trying
to make ends meet those are my people
they get it they get elevation they they
get get into something and turning water
into wine they get well we got to go and
make it happen they get that but those
people want Vegas I don't get that I
love this I love my critics have critics
I just want to say something about your
wife Tracy Edmonds who I know she is
spectacular smart and gorgeous and you
said in the piece that you love your
wife you need your wife as much as you
need toothpaste and we all need
toothpaste I think that's a great way to
put it because we all need toothpaste so
shout out to them yeah Tracy is a
blessing in uh
um trust me she adds so much to me she
either people will add or they subtract
or help you multiply or divide Tracy
adds and helps me multiply well Dion we
appreciate you joining us and I'll make
this prediction even though you were one
of the greatest NFL players of all time
I feel like what you did on the field
were pale in comparison to what you're
going to do as a coach so thank you and
I'm recruiting your son you do know that
right because
I heard it here
you keep on doing what you're doing your
whole crew thank you I love you and
thank you for blessing us every morning
you guys we wake up I appreciate all of
you recruiting
stream coach Prime with the agents
Amazon video